hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
when looking at applications or examples
for utilitarian moral theory one of the
areas that that comes up quite often
is business and workplace issues
and actually if you were to look at
business ethics texts or or similar
texts you would often find discussions
of utilitarianism as a moral theory
in part because it's uh it's an approach
in thinking about moral matters that
makes a lot of sense within these sort
of contexts
because every time that you're dealing
with these sorts of issues you have
something usually that that's fairly
quantifiable
and
reflects or results in in preferences or
orderings
made by various people
and you have a number of different
people's interests or
concerns or
stakes however you want to put it that
are that are in play and have to be
balanced against each other so
this is a mode of moral analysis that i
think is quite familiar at least on an
intuitive level too to many people
involved in
decisions about businesses or about
workplaces in general
now just to review
when we're thinking about things in a
utilitarian way
we're looking for
maximizing pleasure or happiness or
however you want to put it bentham
allows multiple ways to conceive of this
and we're aiming at minimizing pain
but we're looking at it overall so we're
not looking just at one single person
we're looking at the entire community of
people affected so like i put here think
about who is affected
and i've got this word holders there and
there is a long-standing discussion
particularly in business ethics but in
in other sorts of workplace ethics too
so this would apply to
hr to to nursing ethics to all sorts of
other applied ethics
there is a difference between the people
who are stockholders the people who own
a concern the people who
are supposed to be
at least legally
the ones benefiting from it the most
and stakeholders that is the wider
number of people who are affected by
decisions made by by business and we're
going to see that
running through a utilitarian analysis
of all these different types of types of
issues or or problems
so you know it's often framed in terms
of stockholders stakeholders but bentham
would frame it actually in terms of a
sort of narrow conception of
what he calls beneficence doing well to
other people and then a wider expanded
more global understanding of beneficence
so
to recap
it's not just a matter of maximizing
pleasure and minimizing pain
for the people involved in the company
or in the workplace
let alone those who own
the uh the workplace or own the business
or own the concern
it's about everybody who's potentially
affected by it now if it's if it's
potentially affected by it of course as
opposed to definitely affected by it or
certainly affected by it you have to if
you're doing utilitarian calculation you
have to weigh in that probability
as lowering the the amount of concern so
if there's like a one percent chance
that somebody's going to be affected
negatively or positively
you factor in that one percent when
you're doing the calculations
so let's look at some of these issues
one of the issues that is
unavoidable is thinking about the
quality of the work environment this
comprises a lot of different
sub issues you could think for example
about the the safety of a work
environment or
the comfort of a work environment
just in terms of physical
issues not not yet getting to anything
psychological although these will have
psychological effects
so if you're an employer
and
or you know an office manager or
somebody else who's responsible for the
condition of a workplace
and
you have
some sort of decision making power over
the way that that workplace is
experienced by the people working there
or you know even coming in off the
street and entering there
you would want to
make it as pleasurable as possible and
minimize the amounts of pains that could
be encountered in it so you know think
for example about things as simple as
do you paint regularly do you actually
clean the place those would be
issues from utilitarian perspective
small issues nothing quite so big as say
is it an unsafe workplace or is it a
safe workplace
if you're utilitarian you would want it
to be as safe a workplace as possible so
long as the emphasis on safety does not
impinge on other things like you know
actually getting things done or people
enjoying themselves
another issue that would come up in
terms of quality of workplace
environment
would be any kind of discrimination you
know if you're utilitarian
sometimes people will say well if you're
a utilitarian you can single out some
people
within a given area and treat them badly
because you do so at their expense but
that expense pays off
across the board for a lot of other
people
bentham you know
himself if you read his works he would
not be that amenable to that in part
because there's other
quantitatively measurable you know
negative payoffs to doing that sort of
thing so you know think for example
about telling
um
off-color jokes or racist jokes or jokes
that offend religious uh people's
sensibilities or or you know putting up
posters that that irritate the
non-believers in the workplace or things
like that
i would think
from a utilitarian perspective
bentham would be against that sort of
thing
in part because even though
maybe you know you've got like one
person who's uh particularly negatively
affected by it and a lot of other people
get to join in on whatever it is that's
going on
it creates a sense of imbalance it
creates a condition in which
people feel themselves and the feeling
as a kind of pain
feel themselves to be
not entirely at home um
and uh certainly in our diverse society
today and the way that things are set up
doing that sort of thing would provoke
all sorts of other conflict which again
would include other pains although some
people enjoy getting into conflict don't
they
another thing that's very closely
related to quality of work environment
and a lot of businesses there's an
emphasis on efficiency or productivity
and this is an interesting case
to think about because one of the
reasons we've had such a jobless
recovery
over the last three four years
is in part a result of not only
outsourcing things which is a matter of
efficiency but
workplaces have become more productive
and
what productivity actually means
is more work gets done by by less people
or an equal amount of people so you
don't need to hire
new
new people to do that in order to boost
production right you can boost
production by hiring more hands to
actually do things or you can have
processes become more effective more
efficient more productive and then the
same amount of hands can get more done
and
um
if all of your competitors are doing the
same thing within that that kind of
environment where you actually do have
to you know worry about the the costs of
labor
um
yeah that can that can be a real issue
that can that can preclude doing that
now again
you do have to think about this in terms
of stakeholders rather than just
stockholders if if it's just a matter of
profitability of raising the profit
margin
so as to
you know benefit the the stockholders a
little bit more
by squeezing the workers you know harder
and harder and harder bentham would be
against that because there's a lot more
workers and there are stockholders
and most likely the pain the discomfort
that they actually end up going through
you know the risk of say burnout or
collapse or things along those lines
it greatly outweighs the marginal
increase in utility and happiness and
pleasure for the
stockholders
even if you think about stockholders
being distributed across a wide margin
of people because we do have a lot of
people who actually do buy
some stock
now there's trade-offs to this and if
you think about the wider community
maybe bentham you know would look at
this in a very nuanced way
because the entire lifestyle that we
currently enjoy and we have been
enjoying for quite a long time
we're able to buy an awful lot of stuff
fairly cheaply
is
predicated on
more and more efficient productive
organized processes
um that's why we can live a lifestyle
that even though it's not you know great
in comparison to previous um
decades let alone centuries
it's incredibly rich
logistics itself and technology is also
a part of this process you know so
bentham would look at that and he would
say are you boosting the overall
happiness even if you do have some
people who
are out of work
you know
are the people who are out of work
actually able to enjoy all sorts of
benefits that ordinarily they wouldn't
enjoy because of a system
that stresses productivity
there's an argument to be made there and
again i'm not trying to actually provide
exhaustive cost benefit analysis of this
sort of thing i'm just suggesting
lines by which you might kind of work
these things out
another interesting issue
this applies to a lot of products
particularly the more prestigious the
products get
cost of advertising or pr is built into
a lot of products
you may not realize it but when you're
going to buy
brand name items you're paying in in
large part for the packaging for the
the
the image development and enhancement
and continuance that's going on you're
paying for them to give away free
product over here to try to build a
market you're paying for them to
subsidize things over here sometimes
that don't actually benefit you
so the question i guess with that would
be from utilitarian perspective
is that practice of building in all
these sort of costs because of
advertising and pr
is that okay from utilitarian
perspective
now that's an interesting question and i
think there's two things to think about
with that
so one would be
just think about the product by itself
most brand name products are not
particularly
um
great in comparison to a generic
counterpart which tends to be a lot
cheaper
but the generic counterpart tends to
look generic right it doesn't have a lot
of
image appeal
and so if you look at it just on that
basis you know this can of corn versus
uh that can of corn that's coming from
green giant or you know from round well
roundies is more of a
generic one
um
well sells corn well i'll just say that
um pour them both out they look pretty
much the same you're going to get pretty
much the same amount of pleasure out of
eating them
same thing would go for shampoo
um
anything you could you could think of
do you really need to buy gas at this
station as opposed to that station
although gas prices aren't changing that
much
um
a lot of luxury goods really you're
paying in large part for
these sort of costs
and actually a lot of staple consumer
goods you are too
now
if you look at it just in terms of the
physical product
it's kind of dumb
from from a bentham utilitarian
perspective right
do people actually enjoy buying the
things that have the glossy covers and
tie in with their hopes dreams fears
all their other affections that that
advertising appeals to
um do people enjoy drinking bud because
of the you know this you know the
interesting commercials and stuff like
that or coors or pick any other sort of
um and i'm gonna offend some people and
saying this any sort of you know
low-grade craft beer
in doing so
yeah i think a lot of people actually do
buy those sort of products in part
because there's a secondary pleasure
that's involved with that very
advertisement or other forms of pr
that have built a kind of mystique
around the product
and if you're bent them
well that would you know that would
factor into the pleasures and pains
wouldn't it on the other hand if they
really screw up the advertising campaign
um that could work against them in that
respect too
closely related to this
at least structurally different pricing
tiers
this is kind of an interesting sort of
structural issue too
um think about airlines for example
if you're flying coach
now it's no fun these days to fly coach
because they've cut a lot of frills
along the way right to be to remain
fairly profitable even though some of
them are actually in bankruptcy
that one then um
if you're flying coach
you may not realize this but your flight
is in part being subsidized by the
people behind the curtains
so the people in business and in first
class they're paying a lot more for
their seats and they're getting some
amenities that you're not getting so you
know you might have to wait for a pillow
or pay for a pillow they get it you know
automatically supplied
you got to pay for your alcoholic drinks
they get them automatically supplied
if you actually look at what they're
getting for their dollar amount it's
kind of a dumb trade-off on their part
they're not actually maximizing their
pleasure
they are however whether they realize it
or not whether you realize it or not
they are maximizing the pleasure across
the plane
because
they're
paying for
services that are you know
really overpriced
is helping to subsidize the services
whatever they may be
in coach
so
is it okay then to charge some people
premiums
and you could think about this with you
know in terms of
hotels you could think of this in terms
of all sorts of other
other related
topics and
objects and things that we would we
would purchase
does it make sense to sort of distribute
costs and benefits in such a way that a
small amount of people overpay
and it helps out a larger amount of
people from a utilitarian perspective
that's almost a no-brainer
that one actually works out quite well
let's move on now to some you know more
i don't want to say substantive because
these are all substantive talk topics
but you know the sort of traditional
ethics topics like say whistleblowing
right
what is whistleblowing it's when you've
got some sort of practice or product
that actually maybe poses a threat to
some people or violate some people's
rights or you know
the
something is going on that ought not be
going on and it's being covered up it's
not being reported either through the
media or to the appropriate law
enforcement agencies or to the
regulatory agencies
and a whistleblower is the person who
actually says hey hey this is going on
over here i'm going to reveal this to
you
do you have an obligation from a
utilitarian perspective
if you see some sort of practice that's
going on
that is supposed to be reported and
nobody else is reporting it and they
know about it do you have an obligation
to report it
was a good question
you would have to look at how many
people are actually being affected
and bentham you know one of the famous
things that bentham said he called
rights nonsense on stilts why did he
call that why did he talk about it that
way because in his view a lot of times
the the needs of the entire community
were being overlooked by people focusing
on my individual rights over here my
individual rights
so i would think that bentham might
actually be inclined to say
that
there'd be some cases where you
shouldn't blow the whistle
if only a few people are actually being
negatively affected by it
and
disclosure is not really going to bother
too many people
then
don't worry about it if on the other
hand there's a great threat that would
actually put a lot of people's
you know pleasures and pains into into
play
or actually are
currently affecting people negatively
then you would actually have an
obligation to blow the whistle from a
utilitarian perspective
another related topic that you could ask
about which i'm not going to go into
should we be protecting whistleblowers
should we be encouraging whistleblowers
and that's a whole different can of
worms right there
closely related unsafe products
now from a utilitarian perspective
unsafe products
again pretty simple
they're going to be going against the
greatest happiness principle right
because if it's an unsafe product and
it's being widely
promoted widely produced widely
sold
then a lot of people's
lives perhaps
a lot of people's health a lot of
people's um livelihoods pick whatever
you like are being threatened and you're
you're not minimizing pain you're
actually producing a lot of pain and
you're probably interfering with a lot
of people's pleasure as well
this is one of those classic cases where
it's a you know limited benevolence or
beneficence uh really should not get in
the way of universal or general
beneficence
now one thing that you could think about
though
unsafe products
we generally think about that in terms
of the consumer right the people who are
actually um
buying the product so
don't buy uh for example
really a lot of things that come from
china you know
they've got a pretty bad track record
for for environmental um uh
and health um
checking you know and concerns and
things like that
um
it's not a good idea to buy products
that you think might be tainted
and it's not a good idea to be selling
products that are that are tainted
either people do this because they want
they want to gain
something in the process
there's two other
holders who could be affected though
one would be the workers themselves what
we call the supply chain who are
providing these things so if you think
about apple for example apple got
themselves in trouble
in part because it got revealed that
some of these factories that the parts
are being assembled in are coming from
are kind of unsafe the products
themselves are not you know unsafe
they're not blowing up in people's
pockets
when they have them but the workers
themselves the people you know
closer in on the supply end are are
actually being negatively affected the
other thing would be unsafe say within
the larger environment
and this could come about two ways it
could be the production process itself
is unsafe because it produces say
environmental contamination
or it could be that the product that
you're generating is unsafe not
necessarily for the the consumer
themselves but for the other people in
the community who are stuck with you
know this person's products
another thing to think about would be
and then now we're changing um speed
quite a bit applying rules and
procedures very strictly
once you have rules you know do you you
keep them in place and say look here's
the rules everyone's going to be on the
same
level
or do you have some leniency
some discretion in them to allow for
cases so that you might actually you
know locally
work things out so as to minimize pain
and maximize pleasure
this is a real issue uh in terms of say
housing
right people have to live with each
other and we are still you know deep in
a problem with you know overvalued real
estate that then took a dive
people who were lent all sorts of money
who probably really couldn't have
qualified for that sort of money uh in
part because of predatory lending in
part because of you know foolish
government uh interventions that were
motivated by both political parties
uh just in different ways a lot of
different things going on there
think about foreclosures and actually
think about mortgages in general too
i remember years ago listening to a
radio show and this reflected my point
of view as well
where this is just before the bubble
burst um
the radio show host is saying
man you know when i had to qualify for
my mortgage i had to jump through all
these hoops
because you know risk was being
distributed through the system
i i had to you know actually do all
these sorts of things and i was worried
i wasn't going to get get my mortgage
and i had to save so that i actually
could put a down payment down and look
at all these other people that are being
granted them just like you know like
clockwork for some sort of you know
economic or political reason
um what's going on there and he was very
upset and you know that that being upset
that's a that's a pain that needs to be
thought of
um
what about the people whose lives are
made easier by allowing them easy access
to the funds that allowed them then to
buy the houses i guess for a short time
you know so long as everything keeps
going on pretty well they're doing okay
and that that actually maximizes
pleasure for them so maybe we should
ease up on it
now we're in the up with the opposite uh
condition where it's uh worries about
foreclosures should we foreclose on all
these people's homes
should we
help them out
you know should we
use government money to to fund efforts
to get some people out from being as
they say under water or should we say
well you made your bed uh now you have
to be responsible and lying
that would be something that we could do
a cost benefit analysis with from the
utilitarian perspective
two other things i want to talk about
before we end
one is corrupt practices and what we
mean by corrupt practices would be say
nepotism bribery you know other forms of
using influence
to
get ahead in business
now there are some cultures in which
this is the norm and
it'd be interesting to think about what
would bentham actually say about that
in england
at least
in the the places where that had become
the norm bentham was totally against
that because he said it subverts justice
and if you're subverting justice you're
actually producing
pain for a lot of people because you
know although you're producing pleasure
for the people who are able to get over
you're actually making a lot of other
people ticked off because they're
getting screwed in the process and
they're not benefiting from this unjust
arrangement that's going on
you could think about bribery you could
think about
people able to sort of use the system
people drawing on
influence connections and all that sort
of stuff
i think from utilitarian perspective you
can say that's actually a bad idea a
level playing field is probably the best
idea
finally starting a business i wanted to
end on kind of a good note bentham
actually
was a typical laissez-faire liberal of
his own time he's a great admirer of
adam smith
and i think that you know
we can see that even today small
business owners are are in large part
generating rather than just sort of
drawing on sucking out
um
things from the the environment they're
the ones who tend to produce a lot of
innovation
tend to
you know provide a lot of the jobs
available
and that would be in you know from
utilitarian perspective a positive thing
if you're creating new jobs by finding
some some product niche that has not yet
been
been worked in
and that product actually makes people
happy
and you can do this feasibly bentham
would say that's a good thing should we
be encouraging small business provided
as you know not doing stuff like
engaging in corrupt practices or
giving people crappy work environments i
think bentham would say yeah
we should actually be if not promoting
it you know actively at least getting
out of the way
and not
putting making the business environment
so onerous for it we probably should do
a lot of watching out so that the big
giant corporations don't crush the
the smaller corporations and push them
out
bentham i think would be a
great fan
of small business so that's where i'll
leave off a lot of different examples of
business workplace issues that the
utilitarianism figures into
and hopefully this has helped you better
understand utilitarian moral theory